bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
comme chaque semaine nous sommes ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles et dans
cette émission nous allons aller en
roumanie qui est désormais confronté au
problème des déserts médicaux de plus en
plus de médecins roumains souhaitent
s'installer en europe de l'ouest pour
améliorer leurs conditions de travail et
augmenter leurs salaires mais
l'actualité de la semaine ça reste
l'europe confrontée aux scandales de la
viande de cheval mais également à la
réintroduction des farines animales
notre invité sera josé bové mais tout de
suite cette question avec nora m'a dit
qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes
me mouraient pas tous mais tous étaient
frappés
les pays d'abord royaume uni italie
france espagne suède irlande finlande et
les industries findus picard mais c'est
vrai
mais qui est donc ce mal qui répand la
terreur sont ce des animaux malades de
la peste nom du canasson de la simple
viande de canassons
oui mais de la viande de cheval à la
place de la viande de boeuf c'est
prendre les vessies pour des lanternes
non
mais voilà la chaire de cheval est bien
moins cher donc dans les lasagnes cela
fait désordre pensez donc des
industriels augmenteraient leurs marges
en trompant le consommateur non vous ne
pensez pas et derrière c'est la
sacro-sainte question de la traçabilité
qui se pose
alors qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes
qu'y at-il dans nos assiettes josé bové
bon jour en jour vaste question alors
vous êtes député européen français du
groupe des verts vous êtes
vice-président de la commission
agriculture ici au parlement européen
qu'est ce que ce scandale de la viande
de cheval qu'est ce que ça dit du
fonctionnement européen avant est ce que
c'est un scandale européen selon vous
alors moi je dirais que c'est un
scandale au niveau de l'europe mais
c'est un scandale de la chaîne
alimentaire d' envoi de l'agro industrie
c'est là que la logique des bas prix
comme c'est bien d'être expliquée ont
réduit les coûts au maximalise les
profits on est dans celle dans ce schéma
là et donc plus on rallonge la chaîne
alimentaire plus on a une logique
industrielle de la production entre le
producteur et le consommateur va
fatalement on arrive à ce gentil sème
donc ce n'est pas l'europe qui est en
cause dans cette affaire c'est très
clairement un modèle agro alimentaire
qui a été poussé évidemment par un
certain nombre de lobbies et sur
lesquelles la commission malgré tout à
donner son aval depuis le début de cette
affaire l'europe ne cesse de dire nous
on édicte les normes et ensuite c'est
aux pays aux états membres de faire les
contrôles en impression quand même un
petit peu de ce défaut sur les sur les
différents états est-ce que ça
correspond à une réalité ce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne alors c'est
vrai que il ya une agence européenne
sanitaire des aliments la usa efsa en
anglais qui a un contrôle qui est née du
scandale de la vache folle et d'eau
l'idée c'était effectivement qu'on ait
un contrôle européen mais ce sont les
états membres effectivement qui de plus
en plus on la délégation pour agir le
dernier exemple en date c'est sûr
justement le contrôle liée à la vache
folle et bien la commission européenne
vient de dire aux états vous pouvez
arrêter nous on vous autorise à arrêter
tout contrôle sur la vache mais arrêtons
nous un instant là dessus justement ce
que vous dites c'est que la commission
dit maintenant ce n'est plus nécessaire
de faire des contrôles sur les vaches
pour savoir si elles sont si elles sont
malades delà de la maladie de vache
folle c'est terminé s'est terminée le 4
février donc dans un document officiel
que j'ai ici la commission vient de dire
aux états membres vous pouvez arrêter
les contrôles sur la vache folle or on
sait que cette année il ya eu 28 cas de
vache folle donc on voit bien comment
quelle est la logique on est dans cette
logique politique qui évolue d'ailleurs
par le conseil des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement on dirait de renationaliser
les politiques et ça je pense que c'est
très dangereux de ramener les politiques
il faut qu'on ait un véritable contrôle
et une politique européenne et ensuite
les états appliquent cette politique
européenne ne peut pas laisser aux états
la liberté ou non de dire on arrête et
qu'on trouve sur la vengeance ça n'a pas
de sens et bien c'est la même chose sur
les farines animales c'est la même chose
sur la rapid de vienne justement à
propos de cette information-là goût
venait nous livre est donc plus de plus
de contrôle sur sur la vache folle plus
on sait le retour des farines animales
dans l'alimentation des poissons dans un
premier temps est ce que ça veut dire
que finalement la commission européenne
estime qu'il ya plus de danger vis-à-vis
d'eux le sb et puis d'autre part est-ce
qu'elle a pas raison parce qu après tout
peut-être que s'est terminée cette
affaire alors on pourrait l'entendre de
cette manière là sauf que sur le prion
on n'a toujours pas véritablement de
connaissances scientifiques on nous
avait dit que ça pouvait pas passer la
barrière des espèces l'homme a été
contaminé donc on a des vrais problèmes
et puis encore des cas donc le problème
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on a
réintroduit en enclenche le processus
pour introduire des farines animales ce
qui était un véritable scandale d'abord
pour les poissons pourquoi on nous dit
on oublie moi je que les farines
animales d'aujourd'hui ne sont plus
celles de des années 2000 90 et 2000 qui
ont favorisé l'extension de la maladie
de la vache folle est ce qu on répondait
est ce que c'est vrai ce que ces farines
animales ont vraiment changé alors dans
un premier temps on nous dit seuls les
farines animales à partir de porcs et de
volailles vont être données aux poissons
puis ensuite au port puis ensuite aux
volailles ça c'est le le schéma idéal on
est toujours un peu chez les bisounours
puisqu'en réalité on sait très bien qu'à
partir du moment où on est dans ce
processus on aura des dérives avec
justement la même scandale qui s'est
passé pour la viande de cheval qui a été
prise pour de la vache on aura des
trafiquants on aura tout un système
industriel qui va chercher à optimiser
donc comme ça coûtera pas cher d'avoir
des farines animales eh bien on va les
réintroduire et dc 1 2 5 ans j'en sais
rien on aura un nouveau scandale de
farines animales de beauvais on ira mais
on n'avait pas prévu c'est parce qu'ils
étaient dans les textes sauf qu'à partir
du moment où on ouvre la porte pandore
eh bien on se retrouve à nouveau dans un
scandale je vais faire à mon tour le
bisounours pourquoi la commission
européenne les stèles faire ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle autorise le retour des
farines animales pourquoi il n'y a plus
de contrôle sur la vallée de la vache
folle qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière pour
moi c'est très clair on a une logique de
lobbying très puissant aujourd'hui de
l'agro alimentaire industriel
aujourd'hui ils veulent à tout prix et
dans la conquête de marchés donc on a
des marques on a parlé de celles qui
sont le circuit le packaging plus cher
que les produits qui sont à l'intérieur
donc on diminue les coûts et à partir de
là on inonde les marchés donc dans ce
processus industriels effectivement on
doit au fur et à mesure avoir le plus de
liberté au niveau de la circulation des
marchandises et on a un vrai danger donc
la question aujourd'hui c'est comment
pour sécuriser les consommateurs et deux
pour permettre aux paysans de vivre ont
raccourci la chaîne alimentaire on remet
par exemple en service ont reconstruit
des abattoirs de proximité parce que la
restauration collective est importante
et donc senna elle peut se faire à
partir de la proximité l'omi vous
revisitez complètement la politique
agricole commune puisque c'est dans ce
cas de la troposphère et dans le cas du
développement rural qui était un des
chapitres de cette taxe l'objectif très
clairement c'est de relocaliser la
production agricole ce que vous nous
dites en fait c'est que bruxelles pour
des raisons financières et parce qu'elle
est très influencé par part du lobbying
finalement lève les barrières et les
sphères de nouveau qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire dire vous êtes on le sent
scandalisé par par ces affaires est-ce
que vous avez des actions est ce que
comme comment vous allez faire pour
parce que là c'est finalement c'est fait
tout ça c'est fait et donc qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous en tant que
député européen et du groupe des verts
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire d'abord
un c'est le mettre sur la place publique
et le fait que je sois ici au parlement
me permet effectivement
d'interpeller de manière beaucoup plus
large donc là c'est très important
ensuite on va mener des actions au
niveau des différents députés au niveau
des états et en bar et un portrait
interpellé le commissaire qui a mis en
place ces processus parce que c'est pas
parce que c'est autorisé qu on ne peut
pas revenir en arrière et pour moi il
est très clair qu'il faut revenir en
arrière mais au terme si au 1er juin ces
farines sont autorisés dans l'élevage
des poissons eh bien on va mener des
actions publiques pour
appeler au boycott du poisson d'élevage
et on va appeler aussi certainement des
actions pour aller sortir des magasins
ces produits aux farines animales un mot
josé bové delphine batho la ministre
française appelle à la création d'un
d'un label poisson sans farine animale
est ce que ça vous paraît crédible
m'écouter c'est un début sauf quand on
est dans le cadre européen
donc c'est pas au niveau d'un pays parce
que les industriels ou que les
producteurs les pisciculteurs français
disent on n'utilise pas in fine c'est un
première chose simplement le marché est
ouvert et il y aura pas que ce type de
poisson dans les étals donc il faut que
ce soit une législation européenne pour
moi il faut interdire les farines
animales mais si l édition il faut
qu'ils aient un étiquetage obligatoire
comme ça le consommateur il verra marqué
en gros nourri aux farines animales ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils aient envie d'en
acheter merci josé bové d'avoir accepté
cette invitation dans leur hôtel de un
autre sujet d'actualité au niveau
européen c'est celui du budget les 27
chefs d'états vous le savez se sont mis
d'accord sur un budget européen pour les
7 ans à venir évidemment les télévisions
européennes en ont parlé on regarde ce
zapping signait aurélie la face
après 24 heures de combat accord sur le
budget et sur les télévisions
européennes on compte les points david
cameron est proclamé vainqueur
ce fut une bataille entre le président
français d'un côté et le premier
ministre britannique de l'autre sur
l'argent dont a besoin l'europe et sur
qui doit le toucher les médias français
ont déclaré leur président perdant il
affirme qu'il a été abandonné par la
chancelière allemande
alors défaite ou victoire pour l'union
entre la rtbf et les dirigeants
européens les avis divergent tout cela
ressemble à une défaite pour l'europe et
pourtant étrangement tout le monde est
content
c'est un budget pour le futur fioutch
c'était l'objectif que je m'étais fixé
le budget européen heureusement présente
des mesures positives
mais déjà la belle victoire s'effrite le
parlement européen fait entendre une
dissonantes ce budget ne lui convient
pas nous ne pouvons pas accepter que d'à
côté nous exigions des états membres un
assainissement de leurs budgets et je
suis pour cela et que nous commencions
ici à créer du déficit cela nous
interdit de signer un tel budget je ne
le ferai pas
alors nous sommes avec isabelle ory
bonjour les abeilles vous êtes la
correspondante de la radio française
europe 1 ici ici à bruxelles on a
entendu le président du parlement
européen qui montre un peu ses muscles
et qui dit ce budget on va pas le signer
alors c'est vrai que ce qu'on sait peu
c'est que le parlement européen a le
droit maintenant d'opposer son veto à ce
budget est ce que vous pensez que le
parlement européen va avoir le courage
politique de le faire je pense que c'est
vraiment une sorte de cadeau empoisonné
pour le parlement parce que c'est vrai
vous l'avez dit c'est la première fois
ils ont ce pouvoir alors évidemment
c'est tentant on se dit est ce qu'ils
vont s'en servir et ce qu'ils vont du
coup montrer la puissance puisque à part
après tout eux représentent les citoyens
européens face aux états et aux à ce
qu'on a appelé les égoïsmes des états et
en même temps ce parlement européen il
est composé des délégations nationales
aussi on prend la france par exemple il
ya une délégation socialiste a requis ce
qu'elle va faire le parti socialiste
européen a dit qu'il fallait pas voter
ce budget est la délégation socialiste
est ce qu'elle va faire comme françois
hollande sont coincés votre pronostic
c'est quoi moi je pense qu'ils vont ils
vont négocier jusqu en juillet qu'ils
vont obtenir quelques concessions qui
seront peut-être un peu technique à
comprendre d'ailleurs pour pour les
spectateurs mais qui vont leur permettre
de s'en sortir en disant voilà on a
obtenu ça on a par exemple obtenu qu'on
règle qu'on regarde le budget dans deux
ans et là est à mon avis ils vont je
pense qu'ils vont voter ce budget donc
plutôt
sur le fond ce budget est ce qu'il vous
semble être un budget en régression
comme beaucoup de médias l'ont dit
chanceux sur le coup c'est ce qu'on a
dit de manière forte parce que
effectivement le budget il est plus bas
que ce qu'on pensait sur ce qui est
compliqué finalement de le savoir parce
qu'on sait pas très bien ce qui va se
passer sur les septembre il ya eu
beaucoup de débats un peu technique il
ya des des choses qui ont été
introduites qui permet finalement pas de
savoir avec précision ce qu'il faisait
il ya plus d'argent dans les budgets
recherche innovation quand même qu'avant
il y en a moins sûr sur la pac par
exemple qu'avant donc à la fin c'est en
volume global c'est moins que ce qu'on
avait ce que ce que les européens
avaient espéré et en même temps il est
mieux répartie bon finalement à la fin
c'est une demi déception beaucoup de
détracteurs de cette de cet accord dont
qui a été signé ici à bruxelles par les
27 chefs d'états 10 le budget européen
en fait c'est un budget de l'europe du
passé par exemple c'est la politique
agricole commune et serra et ça ne
correspond pas aux besoins de l'europe
du futur est ce que vous partagez cette
opinion chose que c'est un budget des
égoïsmes nationaux sauf que c'est un
budget on additionne tous les intérêts
des différents pays alors par exemple
effectivement les français se sont arc
boutés sur la pac pour maintenir à peu
près les volumes des crédits alors
qu'ils auraient dû accepter qu'on baisse
pour pouvoir plus financer la croissance
ont effectivement de ce point de vue là
c'est un budget du passé mais quand même
cette fois ci il ya plus pour la
croissance qu'il y avait dans les
budgets précédents donc finalement c'est
pas si négatif que ce qui a été dit au
moment de cet accord ici à bruxelles
j'ai l'impression que sur sur le moment
on l'a tous trouvé très négatif mais que
sur le monde c'est très compliqué de
juger un budget campus ses explications
qu'on nous donne sont extrêmement
techniques à ce fonds au coeur de la
nuit ce budget il est désolant faut
quand même voir que c'est moins d'un
pour cent du budget l'union européenne
donc si on se place dans une logique
d'ambition européenne il est désolant si
on se place dans ce qu'il était possible
d'obtenir finalement bon c'est pas c'est
pas elle un désastre merci en tout cas
isabelle ory d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va rester évidemment dans
les affaires européennes et nous allons
partir en roumanie se trouve que on a
pété de vue dans les hôpitaux vous
l'avez peut-être vu comme moi et souvent
des médecins roumains ici en europe de
l'ouest et bien ces médecins manquent
dans leur propre pays là bas ça devient
un désert médical voici un reportage
réalisé en roumanie par marie brémaud et
mehdi sheva la
cnds condamne on vous accompagnez
monsieur
il a un problème
cela fait 13 ans que christian paire
yalouz est médecin urgentiste
il exerce dans le plus important hôpital
public de iasi deuxième ville de
roumanie
l'hôpital saint spiridon tourner tant
bien que mal il faudrait 25 % de
médecins en plus pour sortir du sous
effectif chronique et mal de locaux est
grand il il ya beaucoup de boulot c'est
difficile de dire combien d'heures on
travaille par jour car on travaille
beaucoup aussi sur notre temps libre
pour gagner un peu plus
mais bon par rapport à un romain lambda
c'est vrai que notre niveau de vie est
meilleure mais on doit se former lire
apprendre des autres tout en assumant
notre rôle de parent avoir avoir une vie
mais dites moi quand ça vous fait même
ici que l'on sache qu'il a
j'espère aller respirer profondément
avec son travail l'enseignement et des
extras christian arrive à gagner 1000
euros par mois un salaire peu élevé pour
un métier difficile qui requiert dix ans
d'études il lui arrive d'envisager de
partir en belgique ou ailleurs son
profil est très recherché
récemment j'ai reçu des offres de la
part de plusieurs agences de recrutement
des agences de recrutement qui sont très
agressives elles recherchent du
personnel qualifié pour travailler à
l'ouest de l'europe
à l'ouest de l'europe des déserts
médicaux en roumanie le malaise de
médecins qui se sentent bien souvent
dénigré et souffre d'un manque de
reconnaissance
ici les politiques de santé ne
représentent que 4% du produit intérieur
brut contre 10% en moyenne en europe
isabelle à 30 ans et dans quelques mois
alors a achevé son internat sa
spécialité anesthésie en soins intensifs
elle l'exercera a sans doute pour un
temps tout du moins ailleurs
un pêcheur
ce serait l'occasion d'une nouvelle
expérience dans un hôpital où il y a une
bonne organisation
et des moyens conséquents
au gothard est
normale chez
et bien sûr il y à l'argent tout le
monde sait qu'on est mieux payé à
l'étranger qu'en roumanie
je choisirais bien la france car je
parle la langue et puis j'ai beaucoup de
collègues qui sont déjà et qui ont des
expériences réussies la barre
l'expert
la france et la belgique des
destinations privilégiées
les romains sont francophones depuis
l'adhésion du pays à l'union européenne
en 2007 l'équivalence des diplômes et la
libre circulation le phénomène est
alarmant en cinq ans 14 mille médecins
ont quitté la roumanie alors que sur la
même période seuls douze mille achever
leur internat
en roumanie un peu moins de deux
médecins pour 1000 habitants quand la
moyenne en europe et de 3,7 l'ordre des
médecins roumains assiste impuissant à
une hémorragie qui dure et s'accentue
si ce genre d'exode continue dans
quelques années le système de santé
roumain va péricliter
c'est une situation
très grave mais malheureusement les
hommes politiques roumains ne
comprennent pas à cela et n'ont pris
aucune mesure pour les inciter à rester
dans notre système de santé mais n'ayez
insisté amendé sanatatea longuenesse
à la faculté de médecine de iasi l'heure
est aux examens pour ces étudiants en
première année
bordeaux n'a de cesse
d'aller là bas
pas encore doctor est pourtant un quart
d'entre eux a déjà le regard tourné vers
l'ouest qu'à l'est de l'île de java qui
pense parmi vous qu'il travaillera à
l'étranger est
levé la main ceux pour qui c'est le cas
depuis 2007 cette fuite des médecins
auraient déjà coûté à l'état roumain 3
milliards d'euros une grande partie de
la formation est prise en charge par les
pouvoirs publics alors des voix
s'élèvent pour demander aux pays qui
attire et profite de ses médecins de
mettre la main à la poche une sorte de
juste retour sur investissement pour la
roumanie
voilà pour ce reportage en roumanie
signée marie brémaud et mehdi chebana
retour à bruxelles nous a rejoints sur
ce plateau philippe boulland bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes député vous êtes
députés ppe vous êtes également médecin
et surtout spécialiste des déserts
médicaux est ce que vous êtes étonné que
ces déserts médicaux sont désormais une
problématique roumanie n'ont absolument
pas on sait que le classement des deux
des problèmes de démographie médicale
mais cuba en tête des pays les mieux
dotés la france à peu près 25e mais la
roumanie 65e donc comme il ya beaucoup
de médecins roumains et personnellement
dans mon cabinet j'ai une femme
remplaçante quand je suis au parlement
européen qui est roumaine donc je
connais bien le problème effectivement
nous aggravons ce problème en roumanie
alors justement est ce que vous
comprenez que ces jeunes médecins ou
moins jeunes médecins roumains soient
attirés par des meilleures conditions de
travail et surtout des salaires plus
important ah oui tout d'abord dans votre
reportage on parlait d'un urgentiste il
ya une 1000 euros par mois c'est assez
exceptionnel en roumanie en règle
générale il ya une entre 200 et 400
euros par mois ma remplaçante gagne
beaucoup plus dans les 5000 6000 euros
par mois et c'est quand même beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus intéressant dans des
conditions de travail qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus confortable et
financièrement plus attrayante alors on
se retrouve avec un pays la roumanie qui
est un des taux de médecins d parmi les
plus faibles d'europe on se retrouve
avec 1,9 médecins pour 1000 habitants
c'est insuffisant ah oui c'est
insuffisant nous en france on estime qu'
on est à 2 5 médecins pour 1000
habitants à peu près donc on estime déjà
qu'on est en pénurie de médecins alors
vous imaginez la roumanie c'est c'est
bien bien pires alors on a une question
pour vous c'est une question de vasile
astarastoaie c'est l'équivalent du
président de l'ordre des médecins en
roumanie on écoute tout de suite
quant à existera-t-il un mécanisme qui
va éliminer les inégalités entre les
systèmes de santé des différents états
membres
alors voilà qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cette question à quand une
harmonisation à l'harmonisation c'est
très difficile en europe en règle
générale sur tous domaines confondus il
faut plutôt parler de convergence et
l'harmonisation c'est parfois un gros
mot un peu ici mais je pense qu'il faut
essayer de mettre sur pied des systèmes
qui permettent d'équilibrer voilà c'est
peut-être le terme à retenir
d'équilibrer les problèmes de
démographie médicale en europe et moi
j'avais préconisé il ya un an ou deux
ans dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle que l'on mette vraiment
le focus et les projecteurs sur des
des solutions qui pourraient permettre
de résoudre les problèmes de démographie
médicale et j'avais avancé une une
proposition qui normalement la résolvez
en moins de trois ans basée sur la
télémédecine et cette télé médecine elle
peut s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
territoires européens donc en maintenant
des populations médicale dans les
territoires mais là concrètement qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est un pillage des
médecins roumains la roumanie en train
de perdre tous ses médecins à court
terme qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
régler ce problème alors c'est
individuellement c'est très difficile
parce que quand un médecin roumain
j'ai essayé mon vécu en tout cas vient
vous sollicitez et veut travailler par
la langue est compétent a le droit
légalement de venir s'installer en
france comment refuser voilà maintenant
la problématique des des roumains elle
est différente il faut que l'état
roumain assume aussi le le bas coût des
salaires des médecins roumains donc il
ya une il ya des décisions politiques à
prendre en roumanie et les décisions
politiques à reprendre en europe harry
viennent pas seulement en france on
entendu mais également en belgique qui
viennent également en angleterre ou en
allemagne c'est un problème typique de
l'europe de l'ouest aujourd'hui oui
parce que je pense que les rémunérations
sont plus attractives en europe de
l'ouest en europe de l'est évidemment à
quatre fois supérieure et voilà donc
évidemment rien que ça déjà ça ça pose
le problème ensuite il ya des régions en
france où on a trois quarts des médecins
étrangers qui ne sont pas que roumain
nous avons aussi beaucoup de lui une
population de médecins maghrébins qui
est assez importante donc le vraiment en
france c'est pas du pillage volontaire
mais on ne peut pas ne pas accueillir
des médecins qui en plus nous rendre
service et rendre service à notre
population alors en france il ya un
problème de numerus clausus qui a été
relevé est-ce que c'est pas absurde
aujourd'hui de d'avoir cette limitation
est ce qu'on pourrait pas formé beaucoup
plus de médecins en france si c'est ce
qu'on dit depuis des années et des
années le le numerus clausus a augmenté
de 10% en quelques années c'est ridicule
au regard des besoins de la population
donc on aurait dû il ya longtemps
augmenter encore plus ce numerus clausus
pour autant il faut être quand même un
peu sélectif mais
on a
on n'a absolument pas pur moment de
d'équivalence étant que
et toutes les autres solutions proposées
par les gouvernements ne sont pas ne
permettent pas de pallier ces problèmes
de défauts de médecins soyons clair vous
aviez adressé naître à l'époque à
nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il était présent
la république sur le problème des
déserts médicaux que ce soit des déserts
médicaux en france on en roumanie que
vous êtes pour la liberté d'installation
mais à une condition est-ce que vous
pouvez nous l'a rappelé et il faudra une
période un petit peu de transition avant
de choisir le lieu où on s'installe à
moi j'ai vécu ça dans des pays du
tiers-monde et pays émergents où on a ce
type de dispositif qui marche très bien
et donc je pense qu'en france si on veut
autoriser un médecin tout en maintenant
la liberté d'installation autoriser un
médecin s'arrête dans une zone
relativement correctement dotées ou
surdotées il faut l'obliger à vent à
faire quelques années dans un territoire
sous dotées peut-être ce médecin se
plaire à découvrir à ce territoire
l'adoptera y vivra il restera donc
pourquoi pas c'est un challenge
maintenant après il aura l'autorisation
d'aller ailleurs mais entre temps il y
aura un turnover réguliers sur trois ans
quatre ans d'installation dans ces
territoires sous l'autel déjà rien que
ça ça solutionne une partie du problème
l'autre pan de monde la proposition
était basée sur la télémédecine les plus
optimistes disent que c'est peut être
bénéfique pour la roumanie cet exil des
médecins roumains puisque à long terme
ils reviendront peut-être en roumanie
cela bénéficiera l'ensemble du système
de santé aux mains est ce que vous
croyez à un retour de ces médecins
ensuite en roumanie pas du tout je pense
pas je pense que tant que les conditions
de l'exercice médical en roumanie sont
telles qu'elles sont la date
d'aujourd'hui ils reviendront pas et
ferais vraiment ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure qui est un changement
politique chez eux ce politique social
économique évidemment donc les médecins
qui sont chez nous en france s'y
plaisent s'installe se regroupent
d'ailleurs mme je vois beaucoup de
regroupements communautaires
je pense que c'est gage d'une
installation à long terme il ne faut
rien faire pour limiter les
autorisations les déplacements de
médecins à travers l'europe c'est c'est
le libre échange il faut absolument
laisser faire les choses voilà moi je
pense que la régulation doit doit enfin
le système doit s'auto réguler il ya des
directives qui autorise les médecins à
circuler on la laissait pas le cas
l'autorégulation pour le monde voit
qu'il ya des il ya des soucis justement
sur les pays les pays les pays de l'est
effectivement si les déserts médicaux on
les transfère de la france vers les pays
de l'est y a pas d'autorégulation non il
n'ya pas l'oeil a pas d'autorégulation
mais il ya des directives qui autorise
la libre circulation et ça on est
absolument pour la libre la liberté de
circulation dans l'europe c'est le
principe même de l'europe la liberté de
circulation des biens des personnes des
marchandises des de l'argent donc on va
certainement pas lutter contre ça et les
directives européennes autorisent la
reconnaissance de diplômes dans l'union
européenne donc on va pas remettre ça en
cause je crois qu'il appartient à la
roumanie de faire les efforts
nécessaires pour essayer d'attirer ces
médecins et de les faire revenir le plus
possible et nous on trouvera d'autres
solutions eh bien merci à philippe
boulland d'avoir été avec nous et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
europe hebdo ici à bruxelles avec kathia
gilder et françois beaudonnet bonne sud
est programmé à très bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires